في اصعب موقف يمكن ان يمر به اب وام
يلتقيان ابنتهما قبل نقلها الى غرفه
العمليات
حيره وذهول قبل اتخاذ القرار المر فعلى
الاب ان يوافق على بتر ساق ابنته التي
اصيبت في الزلزال وقتل ولداها
بعد انهيار منزلهم في مدينه حارم
جده تطلع من الباب من المدخل ولا العواميد
نزلوا عليها ولد وليد روحوا
وهي مردومه من هون وهاي الصغيره
والحمد لله ما رايت وهلا اجره ميته بده
يبطروا
المستشفى بالمرضى وذويهم ما يعني مزيدا من
الضغط على الكوادر الطبيه
وقد خلفت اثار الزلزال قصصا لم يعتدوها
مثل وجود رضيع ماتت كل عائلته او جريح لا
يستطيع المستشفى مساعدته لاسباب يوضحها
الطبيب احمد الذي كان في المستشفى لحظه
الزلزال
يعني نقدم احسن خدمه لكل المرضى بسبب نقص
المستلزمات الطبيه الموجوده وخاصه انه نحن
خلال فتره طويله من الحرب يعني تم استهلاك
اغلب المواد وكان في علينا كتير ضغوط
وخاصه فيما بعد وقت اللي صار عنا بعض
الجراحات العصبيه مثل تثبيت الفقرات اللي
احنا بالاساس ما عنا مثلا مواد استجدال
لتسديد فقرات او للكسور العظمي اكمل
الزلزال وما بداته الحرب من احداث اكبر
ضرر بالقطاع الصحي
فتصدع مستشفى الامومه بعد الزلزال اجبر
منظمه سامز على اخلائه بشكل كامل عندما
كان الناس في امس الحاجه اليه
رغم مرور ايام على الزلزال في سوريا ما
زالت المستشفيات تغص بالجرحى ولا يشغل بال
الاطباء حال المرضى فقط بل تامين الادويه
والمستلزمات الطبيه ايضا في ظل ضعف
المساعدات الدوليه التي تصل المنطقه صهيب
الخلف الجزيره ريف ادلب